j'aurais pu épousé une japonaise et puis
en général au japon une gerbe en
japonais épouse japonaise mais j'ai
épousé une femme qui est qui était par
hasard une belle dès le début de notre
mariage
mon mari m'a dit je ne te sens pas une
étrangère dans les rues et moi même si
je n'avais pas aperçu le regard des
japonais me fixant je ne serai pas senti
étranger à dire m'a bien que de temps en
temps mais pour moi j'ai pu réaliser que
oui j'étais grande et blonde elle était
petit et noir
des milliers de jeunes françaises
suissesse canadienne neige ou
luxembourgeoises ont épousé des
étrangers qui les ont emmenés vivre dans
leur pays
qui mieux que ces émigrés par amour
saurait nous parler de ces pays dont
elles ont fait leur deuxième patrie sans
toutefois oublier leur éducation
d'origine c'est le cas de mademoiselle
vandales québec qui pour être tombée
amoureuse d'un professeur de littérature
japonais est devenu une dame de tokyo
quand je suis arrivée à l'aéroport de
haneda suis arrivée au japon ce
débarquer pour la toute première fois
c'était évidemment très émue et puis
j'essaie de reconnaître mon mari parmi
cette foule de petits japonais
et puis tout d'un coup je vois mon mari
s'avancer vers moi avec un énorme
bouquet de chrysanthèmes alors choc
incroyable parce qu'enfin le
chrysanthème pour nous ça représente la
la fleur de la mort est pour lui c'était
le chrysanthème japonais c'était la
bienvenue alors dès les premières
secondes débarquement au japon c'était
un autre monde
optez pour le français de france minimes
y est tu parle un peu japonais aussi oui
pourquoi pas un petit peu japonais
comment t'es tu dis on a remis ses
tontons japonais ça qu'est ce qu'il a
dit exactement a soumis shigeru midi le
nom de famille d'abord qui a soumis
shigeru omi et tu n'as pas un en
français aussi ta maman t'as pas donner
un en français ça me donnerait bien oui
petit belge enfin rohbock comment dit-il
comment tu t'appelles comment sait-on
panneaux belge gpac jean sébastien bach
mais il est japonais je ne suis pas
steinbach non il est quoi il est allé
c'est vraiment sûr présent c'est vrai
nous font ces gens ces pastels mais quel
âge at il
ce qui est jean sébastien bach dont ceux
par qui le 8e temps fait il connaît
beaucoup de gens comme ça dans la
littérature ou la musique
il reconnaît quelques filets de lapin
sur tata ci s'appelle comment bouvard et
qu'ici on dit que je suis vert et
pécuchet
bravo monsieur jean-luc kwata et
monsieur gustave inter flaubert et
monsieur marcel poudre à cette année
marcel proust
fatalement un jour il choisira il y aura
une des deux civilisations qui lui sera
plus proche comment trouvez-vous cette
ville vous aimez est bien vrai dire je
n'aime pas tant qu'on me semble
monstrueux trop de mouvements trop de
bruit trop de foule et puis et puis
c'est laid je me souviens de l'europe de
l'italie évidemment on ne peut pas tout
avoir un développement économique
incroyable et en même temps la beauté
des rues où la beauté de la ville
[Musique]
notez que je suis persuadé que c'est une
ville qui par contre plaît énormément
aux hommes elle est une preuve de
vitalité d'organisation et je sais qu'il
y en a qui sont tout à fait ébloui
sidéré par le nombre de tunnels les
bâtiments élevés
[Musique]
j'attendais beaucoup de spectacles
extérieurs du japon
[Musique]
probablement que je suis mal disposé
vis-à-vis de ses petites rues moi il me
semble sordide mais regardez en europe
on les fait courir sous terre non effet
lectrique tandis qu'ici ça défigure le
paysage
ça fait ville faite à toute vitesse et
puis dans un double pas du tout non pas
du tout justement par rapport à tokyo
qui plaît beaucoup aux hôpitaux est une
ville féminine lorsque plus plus de
charme immédiat
et puis tous les vestiges anciens vous
parler et vous séduisent
heureusement vous vivez ici dans la
banlieue de tokyo
oui 6 non pas parce qu'enfin nous ne
sommes pas encore dans la banlieue c'est
tokyo même qui est énorme
je ne crois pas me tromper en disant que
les loyers sont les plus élevés du monde
c'est à dire qu'il ya tellement de
personnes qui veulent vivre au même
endroit que fatalement les prix sont mon
incroyable et la vie est chère
oui la vie est chère mais enfin plus si
c'est à dire on travaille beaucoup pour
n'avoir pas tellement d'argent mais on
l'a dit qu'au point de vue niveau de vie
c'était la 20e place dans le monde
doivent supporter beaucoup plus de
choses mais en fait justement celle de
leurs caractéristiques
il supporte le japon a l'air embarqué
dans une course folle vers le progrès le
modernisme
c'est incontestable mais n'y a pas que
le progrès industriel il ya des gens qui
sont lents qui sont rêveur qui sont
poètes
200 à l'heure ah là là même en allant
wagon restaurant pour se distraire non
non ça va trop vite j'ai peur pas qu'ils
se sont pris d'une folie pour le
baseball la wii alors ça je te dire que
mon beau-père chaque soir c'est le
baseball le baseball dans le golfe aussi
il paraît que c'est devenu une wii
probablement que le golf il ya le côté
nature qui leur a plu aussi on marche
beaucoup dans des grands espaces verts
et ils sont très adroits ça évidemment
manuellement
ils sont extrêmement adroit c'est pas
nouveau
[Musique]
une influence étrangère extérieur ne
porte que sur des choses matérielles sur
des détails de vie courante mais sans
doute pas sur la mentalité leur base est
suffisamment riche personnel puis il
croit que ce sont les meilleures
traditions depuis l'europe quant aux
vans japonais on a tout de suite un
attirail qui vient à l'esprit
un mélange de scènes d'aïkido de judo de
tir à l'arc un peu mystique
c'est comme ça que je dis aime de tout
ça ça me semble comique
[Musique]
et on imagine un peu que tous les
japonais sont des gens profondément
mystique d'une façon mystique mais pas
comme nous on fait envoyer autrement
nous on va vous et moi j'ai jamais
rencontré une japonais mystique par
exemple jamais parler de religions
japonaises avec mon mari on parle
d'autre chose non vraiment la salle
munie de zen au non non non surtout pas
des noms là là ce sont les français ou
les européens qui définissent le zen
mais surtout pas les japonais
non mais vous voyez par exemple une
chose comique j'adore le poisson cru et
les algues et m'ont marqué japonais et
bien une autre horreur je sais vraiment
du poisson cru
ah oui oui mais le cru être crus coupés
en petits morceaux et puis on mange avec
du riz et je trouve cela délicieux
l'autrement chez vous d'habitude vous
mangez plutôt européens ou japonais mais
un compromis mais ceux qui restent en
tout cas ça commence du riz tous les
jours mais par exemple vous inviter des
japonais ils vous répondent oui avec
plaisir vous compter dessus
et puis viennent pas alors mon mari m'a
expliqué ce qui comptait pour eux c'est
de ne pas avoir dit non en face j'avoue
qu'au début vraiment jeu j'ai eu du mal
tout de même à m'adapter parce qu enfin
pourquoi est-ce toujours à moi faire les
efforts pour quoi ne pouvait-il pas
s'adapter un petit peu à maman qualité
m
plon
ils ont un incontestable avantage sur
nous ce qu'ils nous connaissent très
bien tandis que nous qu'est ce que nous
connaissons du japon au fonds sont tous
lui ont appris la langue de nous
rés
si je
elle s'y joue
pourquoi ce
toi
un colis
il n'hésite pas à puiser ce qui leur
semble bon et à l'intégrer on pique on
copie mais on ajoute quelque chose en
plus qu'est ce qui vous agace le plus au
japon finalement la lenteur les jours où
je suis mal luné est ce que par hasard
il ne serait pas vive d'esprit
terriblement vive d'esprit
alors ils sont lents comme de réaction
extérieur alors au fond tout ce qui fait
que j'apprécie la qualité de discrétion
et de lenteurs du japonais peu dans la
vie courante mais que ça se perd il vous
a parfois un peu agacé au début par une
certaine lenteur de réaction
oui mais moi je n'y a qu'à ses normes et
mansi sans doute par une grande
oxydation
c'est à dire que quand on pose une
question lieu d'avoir une réponse rapide
est tout à fait précise qui vous
satisfasse pleinement bien le japonais
d'abord hésitant garde le silence
et puis tourne autour de la question je
n'ai jamais jamais oui ou non non c'est
peut-être sans doute durablement
japonais serait pas un peu normand par
hasard est ce que vous pouvez dire que
votre mariale d'humour ah oui beaucoup
et puis c'est sous quelques formes se
manifeste-t-il mais une perception aiguë
du ridicule des des attitudes des
paroles hull
c'est à dire que c'est dit que le
directement du sens de l'observation
comme ils ont un sens observations
incroyable par exemple
je te rappelle au début dans les métro à
paris je disais que vu cette dame en
face comme elles étaient ceux ci comme
l'était ça alors et musées mais oui j'ai
tout vu j'ai dit comment tu as pu voir
parce que tu avais les yeux baissés tu
regardais le boutonneux de tes souliers
ah mais oui mais justement le regard
japonais c'est en un clin d'oeil on a
tout compris on a tous vu on a tout
enregistré et est en effet vitesse
d'observation oui finalement on finirait
par croire qu'ils ont les yeux [ __ ]
parce qu'ils sont plissées par la
tension est vive mais alors qu'est ce
qui vous fait rire
eh bien ça je crois juste que non non il
me fait pas rire mais ce n'est pas par
la parole c'est de créer une un bien ce
comics et drôle par les gestes par la
manière dont dont on dit les choses qui
n'est pas qu'ils ne sont pas du tout
drôle c'est créer une ambiance
mais lorsqu'il m'a fait rire aux larmes
une fois au début de notre mariage entre
dans la salle de bain je vois mon mari
assis par terre je dis mais qu'est ce
que tu fais là il me répondait je me
lave mais je dis comment tu te laves
mais oui avant d'entrer dans la
baignoire alors là ça pour moi c'était
l'asile à ions plomb
cool
sur le plan sentimental est ce qu'il ya
une différence de réaction et de
comportement il m'a semblé que le
japonais était qu sentimentale
n'enfreignent pas que le sentiment
amoureux
le respect vis-à-vis du commerce à qui
il achète des fruits c'est un sentiment
le respect vis-à-vis des parents c'est
un sentiment
[Musique]
je
il me semble que par exemple le français
où le belge ne valorise plus le
sentiment contraire le dénigrer le
mépris je suppose tout de même que la
condition féminine n'est pas des plus
joyeuses au japon c'est-à-dire malgré
tout sans doute que c'est assez consenti
de la part de la femme mais en fait il
me semble encore sacrifié et en ce sens
que son mari travaille et bien elle doit
rester seul vous me direz que ça se
passe comme ça en europe aussi mais
c'est un fait établi et on ne se penche
pas sur la question
il paraît que c'est une préoccupation
typiquement la dig de s'occuper des
femmes que les femmes sont présentes g
oui alors pour les japonais ils me sens
que secondaire on pense au travail un
premier lieu mais on adore les femmes de
loin avec une distance d'environ donné
raison ce n'est pas une expression
directe de s'occuper des femmes
nous sommes aussi souvent et autant mais
de loin et adorée de loin pour vous
pouvez lire je suis amoureuse de mon
japonais parce qu'ils les japonais aux
80% de raison c'est parce qu'ils
allaient le meilleur des qualités
japonaise
et vous monsieur v je ne connais pas
très bien les belges mais je ne pense
pas que ce soit pour la nationalité bien
par la sensibilité étrangères que j'aime
ma femme c'est une totalité de
sensibilité de sentiments ou de la
manière dont elles expriment les choses
mais je crois que nous nous sentons pas
exotique l'un pour l'autre c'est ça la
france est mali vous savez et japonais
n'a pas le sens de la fête
il est fameuse fête japonaises sont
toutes des choses très rituel très
organisé très précise mais ça n'a pas du
tout le caractère de la fête spontanée
comme en amérique du sud où comme à
l'oktoberfest
moi je crois que c'est tout à fait
spontané joyeux mais ce n'est pas
extérioriser d'une manière excessive
marie dit c'est du folklore facile et
que au fond toutes ces fêtes ont perdu
leur caractère véritable et en somme le
singeries maîtrise alors je n'en crois
pas un mot et c'est ce qui me plaisait
de plus l'idée que je me faisais du
japonais même avant de le connaître
c'est que on peut deviner une vie
intérieure qui ne soit pas exprimé de
but en blanc ou avec excès alors
justement c'est ce qui m'a plu chez mon
mari c'est ce côté discret secret
c'était sorte eu deux visages immobile
qui n'en pensent pas moins
[Musique]
quand je suis retourné en europe il m'a
semblé que les visages européen était
extrêmement grimaçant que les êtres
était gesticulant et chez les japonais
un calme qui me plaît a fini et je ne
vous aime pas arrivé à un certain moment
de dire qu'un une japonaise n'aurait pas
eu cette réaction
ça je crois bon exemple
quand on est sortis de cinéma à paris où
on a vu un bon film mois par la nature
japonaise moi j'aurais gardé le silence
en pensant que ma femme apprécié de sa
part dans son silence
mais elle a commencé à parler
immédiatement telle est l'image était
belle telle prise de vue et est
magnifique tout ça alors au début ça m'a
choqué un peu mais là c'est lui n'est
pas une communion dans le silence que
qu'on exprime ce qu'on ressent c'est le
choc
si je vous demande si vous êtes heureuse
mais je vous réponds
très heureuse le plus heureuse qu'on
puisse être mais d'autre part je me sens
je me sens être devenu un peu japonais
et au fond votre question me surprend et
me laisse sans voix parce qu'il me
semble que c'est la chose même qu'on
exprime pas compte pas et que votre mari
n'aime pas vous voir parler si longtemps
pour exprimer des choses
ainsi il me dira ce soir qu'est ce que
vous lui direz ce soir tu as trop parler
tu es tu as bien été européenne sinon je
mets ma main seulement sur ses cheveux
et ça veut dire quoi ça fait une
critique non de sa part ça exprime et de
ma part j'ai à comprendre par exemple
c'est très difficile pour moi de dire je
t'aime où je vous aime parce qu'un
japonais ça n'existait pas ça n'existe
pas une expression qui est correspond
qui correspond exactement à je vous aime
je t'aime il m'a fait avancer beaucoup
dans ce langage muet qui d'abord me
semblait uniquement source de
malentendus d'agacement de frustration
et maintenant eh bien on se comprend on
n'est pas obligé de tout dire
et au fond plus on exprime moins nantis
profondément voilà donc une belge qui
n'a plus la parole avec son mari
japonais rassurez-vous d'ailleurs elle
s'arrange quand même pour avoir le
dernier mot
la preuve alors c'est sûr si ma femme me
critique de parler un peu trop
[Musique]